alors jean pierre mocky le 8 juin sort
un film qui s'appelle une nuit à
l'assemblée nationale c'est ce que tu
racontes en ce moment sur toutes les
radios et surtout que calais promotion
du film on est en mer de faire la
promotion
bah c'est à dire que comme je tourne
beaucoup j'ai peur un petit peu que les
gens
finissent par en avoir main paraît là je
change de chaîne la méfiance est
toujours meilleure dans deux de vendre
un film trop souvent alors ils tombent
les sujets sont différents j'espère que
les gens se lassent pas mais non ça va
ça va pour le moment il faut c'est un
peu comme les chanteurs nous on a en
effet de faire une promo parce que le
spectateur il ya tellement de fismes que
spectateur finit par s'y perdre et donc
il faut quand même lui donner un petit
peu l'idée de ce qu'on présente alors
c'est pour ça que je suis là et ça me
fait plaisir d'être là d'ailleurs comme
tafer cinq films en deux ans là tout le
monde te dis que tu tournes trop
j'imagine que tu tournes beaucoup alors
oui les ricains ans à l'époque les
ricains john ford les grands rica les
jeunes john wayne et caetera et clark
bible en 33 il a fait neuf films dans
l'année mais c'était clark est quand
même génial ans et 50 ans mais parce que
à l'époque on enchaîne les films d'abord
il n'y avait pas de télé il y avait pas
d y avait pratiquement rien donc le
cinéma c'était une nécessité il fallait
en faire beaucoup pour qui pour
alimenter les simples qui les filment
changer toutes les semaines presque un
an 30e demande toujours si tu bat le pas
ouais mais bon allez bâclé ça veut rien
et a bâclé c'est d'ailleurs qu'en fait
quand les mecs fignole trop parce qu'il
ya des films qui sont fignoler seulement
c'est chiant fignoler parce que quand on
tourne trop longtemps les mains qu'il
commence à s'endormir dans leur rôle
il faut les prendre sur le vif c'est un
peu comme le reporter le mec qui prend
une photo dans la rue
6 il flashe pas le type tout de suite et
bien le guet apens d expression et
sans faute sur gravier etc il est
mauvais donc moi j'essaye d'attraper les
mails sur le vif et cernes c'est ça qui
donne le côté bâclé mais en même temps
c'est ce qui donne la vie la vie c'est
et leos carax qui met trente six
semaines pour faire son film toi t'es
pas non parce que les os les oscars as
m'amuse c'est un godard qui ré lentement
parce que des gens lui qui va de ma vie
que lui c'est un mec qui fait des trucs
que les gens comprennent pas mais ça va
vite dans négation ils voulaient
descendre
voilà ces applications prenez un crayon
sur une nappe il dessinait tandis qu' il
ya des pannes qui peignait des fleurs
pendant des mois et puis c'était une
belle fleur une manne en rose mais
c'était la rose qu'on voyait dans un
vase quoi sanaa vers l étranger
alors t'as fait quoi 28 films d'assaut
ça va falloir anti m suis là encore ça
jean-pierre jamais jamais un césar non
mais je n'aime pas les jeunes à cannes
on sait on n'est pas à l'école on peut
pas un filet déprimerait quand j'étais à
l'école j'avais jamais pris parce que
pour avoir un prix fallait vraiment
turbine est bien avec les propres est
toujours à l'heure etc
et moi j'ai jamais voulu avoir de prix
quand j'étais en classe donc quand je
suis dans nos rêves là non le padd
projet med avance sur recettes n'ont pu
non plus tôt ce qu'on a dit toute façon
on me disait tu poses il y en a plein
oui et alors quand il dit qu'il a la
place ça veut dire qu'ils se démerdent
pour en avoir parce qu en fait dans
notre métier ça métier et de des merdes
et systèmes b alors le système d ça
consiste à trouver du pognon parce qu'un
producteur andy producteurs c'est-à-dire
produire quelque chose mais ça veut pas
dire filer le pognon parce que fils et
le pognon c'est financier producteurs
c'est un mec qui a pas de pognon qui en
gros c'est pas pareil lorsqu'il énormes
il ya cinq ans après snob avec une telle
est on
en appartement qu'elle allait être
saisie vite et aller rue de valois du
total
malraux et 179 voix la cessation 61 non
ben oui ça m'a permis de ne pas sauter
quoi passer un film qui plaisait papy
qui devenu un classique a pareillement
pas ça c'est toujours le même problème
les films qu'ils deviennent des
classiques c'est des films qui marchent
pas au départ alors une nuit à
l'assemblée nationale en fait un peu en
faire un peu de promo la cinq semaines
de tournage une semaine de montage suite
des maires de le sortir entre les deux
tours des législatives tu savais que
mitterrand et dissoudre non non sens
même si je suis pas devin passé quand je
ferme ont l'habitude on m'a dit vous
aviez prévu le et elle l aimait qui se
fait 36 morts dus aisé non non ça tombe
quoi c'est un coup de bol on attend ce
moment avec tapis là ça serait bien oui
alors l'idée c'est en gros je vais le
raconter à ta place parce que vu qu'il
raconte toute la journée je vais te je
vais t'aider donc michel blanc il a il a
aidé son village s'appelle terabyte il a
aidé son village
donc on lui parce qu'il a fait un camp
de naturistes wayana d'ailleurs
villecresnes à champigny à des mecs ils
vivent toute l'année dans des camps
comme ça à poil c'est complet il
voudrait d'ailleurs qu'être un poil
toute l'année c'est à dire que leur
problème c'est qu'il voudrait pouvoir
les allées prendre le métro à point ce
serait d'ailleurs leur idéal comme les
com lesquels les pygmées ou je sais pas
quoi il en est un sec mail retourné vers
le paradis terrestre les gens étaient
nus au paris théâtre alors que ce type
là se trouve confronté à une arlette
laguiller qui est avec une maille en
attendant voilà alain strub rouge elle
se présente sachant qu'elle sera pas élu
d'ailleurs la plupart des mains qui se
présentent à part les deux premiers
tours ils savent pas qu'ils vont ils
savent très bien qu'ils seront pas élus
et alors à partir de là cette dame qui
évite d'ailleurs allé à moitié un petit
peu fall est ambivalente elle marche à
voile et à vapeur les ailes à une vie
sexuelle assez curieuse parce que c'est
comme si un patron un endroit pas il est
un petit peu bon masculine
et puis yahia poiret qui fait le
royaliste mais pas mettre le front
national à retenir royal a d'ailleurs
atteint pour les royalistes ou dit non
parce que c'est vrai mais en vérité il
est normal qu'il y ait rameurs la liste
non mais il ya quand même un petit point
commun c'est qu'ils vont à l'église
saint nicolas les charges et violent
alors tout ça les rôles de les rejoindre
parce qu'on dit la messe en latin dans
les fêtes jean non c'est vrai c'est vrai
nom motion des gens des purs b enfin des
pions mais dès les royalistes y en a
très peu
ils sont même pas représenté il se
présente pas à donner présidentielle ce
qui sont position contre le président
pointe voilà donc en réalité ce prêt se
garer ben il ay la trouille ce pouvoir
est là il monte un trafic de légion
d'honneur qui a existé d'ailleurs ça a
sauté à cause de ça oui alors donc j'y
vois là il est dans un trafic qui est
plus que montblanc et mayans découvre le
trafic qui veulent s'en servir pour pour
rôle pour le dénoncer pour faire une
campagne compte pour donner un petit peu
de sel alors à leurs déclarations à
télévision tu regrettes pas battu
regrette pas car l'acteur quoi mais je
joue de temps en temps je fais de
baudart quand même oui mais là quand
oui mais il faut savoir ce qu'ils font
on a plusieurs cantons mais qui a
plusieurs cordes à son arc et un sportif
il peut se rembourser mais s'il joue
bien au football et au mes qui joue
cessé en soit c'est bien la façon dont
ça s'est passé
jean regrette bien sûr d'être dans gta
classe de jouer avec le b avec bella
eric lequel j'apprends qu'on tournait
d'ailleurs mais ça va venir et bébel
était mon copain et puis finalement
bébel est devenu très connu et moi je
suis devenu un metteur en scène
disons que ça me fait un peu de la peine
des rétros maintenant activement je me
j'aurais bien aimé être comme ça à la
une d
innover c'est vrai qu'ils avaient fait
des essais pour le surpoids et que c'est
gérard philipe quel rôle a été beaucoup
plus en place un stadier avait déjà
qu'on est à un moment donné que les
membres ou les jeunes
il voulait un inconnu alors évidemment
il a fait faire des essais à pas mal de
jeunes dont j'étais et gérard était plus
vieux que moi donc il l'a pris parce que
parce que c'était une vedette et qu' il
fallait une vedette pour le film
autrement ce qui ne se monte pas donc
c'est la vieille histoire de du mec qui
finit par l'acteur on de ces combats les
un caprice qui devait faire et était
morte a lancé adjani qui l'a fait il
faut c'est un peu le même truc que tu as
peur de rentrer dans l'ordre au nom
parce que les sujets que gérée par heure
non j'ai pas récupérer parce que d'abord
j'aurais pas de césar j'irai pas au
festival de cannes et puis j'ai
tellement de films à faire j'ai
tellement de trucs à droite à gauche à
faire beaucoup de trucs tu as quel âge
60 piges là non j'ai 58 ans s'est pas
tout à fait souvent presse c'est presque
60 je ne sais pas encore mais je les
aurai dans deux ans
non mes 60 ans ça veut rien dire parce
que
houston il en avait 4 ans quand il est
mort et charles vanel avec julien toyer
la 95 donc ça veut rien dire
aujourd'hui 60 ans et quand j'aurai 60
ans dans deux ans j'aurais quand même
c'est 35 vie mais je pourrais avant
encore autant les clous être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu